[Música]
y en directo a vamos a Ecuador la
fiscalía anunció que solicitará cargos
de corrupción en contra del expresidente
Lenin Moreno y más de 30 personas por
presunta corrupción en torno a la
construcción de la planta hidroeléctrica
más grande del país los hechos habrían
ocurrido entre 2009 y 2018 cuando Moreno
se desempeñaba como vicepresidente de
Rafael Correa ampliamos esta noticia
desde quito con nuestro corresponsal
Gustavo Ortega Gustavo muy buenas noches
cuéntenos Cuáles son las alegaciones de
la fiscalía para involucrar al ex
mandatario
Sí muy buenas noches Andrés la fiscal
general del estado ha pedido a la corte
Nacional de Justicia fije hora y fecha
para la audiencia de presentación de
cargos por supuesto cohecho en contra
del ex vicepresidente Lenin Moreno por
el caso sino hidro se refiere a la mega
obra hidroeléctrica más grande del país
que ha estado envuelta en innumerable
denuncias de corrupción Lenin Moreno
será procesado por presunto cohecho el
cual se refiere a presuntos beneficios
económicos que habría recibido a cambio
de detener omitir o eh De igual forma
no tomar decisiones referente a su cargo
de igual forma también la fiscal general
del estado ha dicho que existe una
estructura de corrupción que está
presente luego de realizar
investigaciones desde el año 2019
recordemos que se mantenía
investigaciones de esta hidroeléctrica
una mega obra hidroeléctrica del país
que siempre ha estado envuelta de
corrupción finalmente Gustavo Quiénes
son los involucrados y porque el caso
tiene tanta relevancia en el país andino
bueno además de Lenin morero están
involucrado 37 personas que incluye
inclusive a la esposa de leriny Moreno a
dos hermanos y dos cuñados de Lenin
Moreno porque es tan relevante bueno
porque la obra costó 3 mil millones de
dólares ha estado envuelta en grandes
denuncias de corrupción se conoce
inclusive que desde su inauguración en
el año 2016 no ha sido entregada
totalmente a el estado ecuatoriano por
el cual se ha conocido según informe de
más de 18.000 fisuras una de algunas de
ellas han sido resueltas con siete tipos
de soldadura pero también se conocen de
problemas en sus turbinas y diferentes
partes de su estructura porque ha sido
tan emblemática porque ha estado
envuelta en diferentes hechos de
corrupción